that's it one of the two biggest cases
everybody was looking for gay marriage
it has now legalized nationwide by the
US Supreme Court that is the opinion
that was just handed down
that's according to headlines that are
crossing right now what this High Court
ruling does essentially is bring gay
marriage to the final fourteen US states
that did not allow it Pam this is
something that there was some
expectation was coming
based on the Supreme Court's decision to
allow 17 lower court reversals of
same-sex marriage bans go forward over
the last several months but again this
is the final one that everybody has been
waiting for related to same-sex marriage
this ruling was five to four in favor of
legalizing same-sex marriage nationwide
so guys the two prime cases everybody
was keeping an eye on the Affordable
Care Act and on same-sex marriage both
now done both really ruling in favor of
the Obama administration same-sex
marriage specifically though dealing
primarily with those last fourteen
states that had same-sex marriage bans
those are now gone individuals because
of the Supreme Court nationwide can now
legally marry and fill
does this mean that any of those states
that would have to change their laws
that they would have to in a sense do
this tonight I mean what does this mean
I think the timelines gonna be really
interesting it probably won't be
addressed in the opinion but by all
accounts folks advocates that I've been
talking to you over the last several
weeks leading up to this they believe
there's not going to be a lot of lag
time here this is something they want to
move forward on quickly
there isn't much after the Supreme Court
right there's not a there's not going to
be Appeals there's not gonna be anything
like that I think what's going to be
interesting pin is there are state
lawmakers state legislators that are not
going to appreciate this ruling in any
way shape or form so they are going to
try and figure out ways around it or to
address it before the time being guys
this is the be-all end-all and I think
the expectation is marriages will be
happening very soon all right so the
Supreme Court now says same-sex couples
have the right to marry in all 50 states
but we just want to bring up a map that
shows where across the nation you up
until today we're not allowed to get
married if you were a gay couple
previously it was recognized in all the
states along the coast you can see the
West Coast and of course certainly the
East Coast pin with the exception of
Georgia
there but now the states that had not
recognized that same-sex marriage the
Dakotas Nebraska Texas of course the
Mississippi Alabama Georgia Kentucky
Ohio Michigan as well as Tennessee so
the 14 states of which it was not
possible that is now going to change and
again Phil you were saying that this is
not immediate what kind of reaction have
we gotten if any what's gonna be really
interesting to see look there have been
people camped out waiting in front of
the Supreme Court for this decision
specifically it also happens in advance
of directly in advance of Pride weekend
the expectation up to this point has
been this was what was going to happen
it was going to be five to four and it
was going to be in favor of making
same-sex marriage legal nationwide so
it's not like there was a huge shock or
that there was even a lot of question
whether it was going to happen I think
the reaction again guys that's going to
be most interesting is not on the
federal level it's going to be on the
state level I think there's going to be
a lot of a feeling amongst some of those
legislators you were just pointing out
of states that have bans in place here
that there's got to be some type of way
around this I think largely though at
least on the federal level when you talk
to Republicans many of whom have been
opposed to this and remain opposed to
this they recognize the writing on the
wall and that's public opinion the shift
over the last not just the last five
years guys the last twelve months on
this issue has gone completely against
where they're standing right now and so
I think the expectation at least
nationwide are on the federal level guys
is that they're gonna let this be they
can be opposed to it but there's not
going to be any major move to try and
get around it you've been covering of
course the campaign for the 2016
elections to what extent have the
thirteen announced candidates in the GOP
talked about this at all they've given a
firm position given that we knew this
decision was coming yeah this is a
complex issue for candidates in a
Republican primary and here's why if you
look at most of the campaigns for
established candidates top two or three
tier candidates they recognize these
poll numbers they're looking at the poll
numbers if they want to get to a general
election they're very wary of taking a
really hard line stance on this however
when it comes to primary States
specifically if you want to look at Iowa
or evangelical Christians play a very
very large role in that prime
right social issues are issues that they
have to talk about I think you I've
spoken to Jeb Bush about this you talk
to people at the campaign for Scott
Walker places like that they're not
going to approve of this they're not
going to support this decision right now
they are against same-sex marriage they
believe marriages between a man and a
woman but this becoming a major issue on
the campaign trail is something that for
the large part they don't want to happen
the exception there that I think he will
absolutely hear from today is Senator
Ted Cruz he has been talking about an
amendment a constitutional amendment to
ban gay marriage in general he has
introduced that on Capitol Hill he's
made it a point in his stump speech and
I think you're going to hear them him
speak very publicly about this but in
general skylit in the Republican field
there's a recognition of these poll
numbers that this not social issues
economic issues are what they would
prefer to focus on fill the decision was
five to four not the six to three vote
that came down yesterday on Obamacare
does this five to four vote mean
anything when it comes to the campaign
trail I don't think so guys I think this
was in line with what people's
expectation was presumably and again I
haven't really dug in on the opinion yet
but that Anthony Kennedy was going to be
the swing vote here and again I think
the tea leaves which can be so difficult
to read on Supreme Court cases I think a
lot of us have made a lot of mistakes
predicting things in the past even
probably some people yesterday with the
Affordable Care Act ruling the tea
leaves were very clear here it was their
willingness to allow seventeen states to
have legal marriages over the last
couple months it made very clear that
there were five justices that were in
support of this the other forward very
clearly stated during the argument
process so this wasn't something that
they were going to support so that fifth
justice likely Anthony Kennedy siding
with them made this the 5-4 opinion that
we saw of him I don't think that
necessarily translates to the campaign
should I think that largely was what the
expectation was all right I want to
thank you very much Phil Mattingly